so it is the holiday season as you know  so we're bringing back a good day Las  Vegas tradition it's Flutie Tooty Friday  over the next few weeks he'll be playing  some holiday Classics so the big  question is what's up this morning well  we obviously there's a ton of holiday  favorites that we all know and love  going way back in the day but if you  haven't already done so perhaps it's  time to  deck the hall  [Applause]  Peppa  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  Pig  [Applause]  baby  baby  foreign  deck the hole so we're gonna do Flutie  Tooty Friday going up into the holidays  uh hopefully on every Friday yeah and we  hope that you are decking your holes I  know you've decorated my walls are  decked  I'm still waiting my Halls are not are  undecated I'm gonna have to help you out  John yeah  at Thanksgiving thank you